gerne Entlastung beim Wohnen danach
sieht es aktuell allerdings nicht aus am
Wochenende ging die letzten drei
atom-meile in Deutschland vom Netz
Energieexperten befürchten jetzt noch
höhere Strompreise für die Verbraucher
gleichzeitig plante EU den nächsten
preisschopf für Bürger und Industrie
Verkehr Schwerindustrie und auch das
Heizen daheim soll klimaneutral werden
wer viel CO2 ausstößt muss ich mit
verschmutzungszertifikaten frei kaufen
und die werden ja um ja verknappt und
immer teurer betroffen sind auch die
Verbraucher die sollen ab 2027 für
Heizöl und Gas ebenfalls Zertifikate
kaufen müssen die
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
verteidigten plante nur so ließen sich
schließlich die Klimaziele erreichen
industriever verwendet und auch
Verbraucherschützer laufen Sturm und
befürchten Nachteile im globalen
bettbewerb die EU rechnet mit Einnahmen
von 700 Milliarden Euro durch diese
Zertifikate und dieses Geld soll dann
zurückfließen ein besonders
umweltbewusst bewusste Industrien und
Bürger Herr das wiederum das klingt doch
eigentlich fair natürlich das klingt
alles ganz großartig und fair die Frage
ist nur wer diesen hohen Preis bezahlt
das löschen darf nicht teurer sein als
der Brand wir versuchen ein Klima zu
retten wo Deutschland übrigens ein
Prozent für die ganze Weltklima beiträgt
das heißt wenn wir alles auf Null Fahren
merkt das Klima das überhaupt gar nicht
denn 99%
machen weiter wie bisher nur wir gehen
das Risiko ein damit a unsere Wirtschaft
kaputt zu machen B die Arbeitsplätze zu
vernichten schon jetzt hauen ja große
Betriebe aber auch mittelständische
Familienbetrieben und so weiter schon ab
ins Ausland und der Witz ist ja wir
schaffen
Kernkraftwerke ab um das Klima zu retten
obwohl das die
klimaneutralsten und besten
Energiespender überhaupt sind und kaufen
Atomstrom aus Frankreich und gerade
erzählt mir mein türkischer
Taxifahrer ganz Scholz die Türkei baut
jetzt zwei Atomkraftwerke Finnland baut
jetzt wir werden umzingelt von
Atomkraftwerken aber wir Deutschen sind
die guten das ist doch toll wir sind die
besten die allerbesten viele fragen sich
natürlich auch wenn man das Ganze weiter
dreht der Bruder was bedeutet das für
viele Verbraucher wird irgendwann das
Fliegen quasi nur noch ein Luxus gut für
solche die meisten können und die
anderen die bleiben halt am Boden nein
die bleiben nicht am Boden die gehen zum
nächsten Baggersee ist ja auch ganz
schön ich es muss ja nicht mehr Mallorca
oder Island sein nein wir leben gerade
eine Demobilisierung das Auto fahren
wird teuer das Fliegen wird oder
schwindelig und vor allem es gibt diese
Ideologie des zu Hause Bleibens und das
hat in der Tat mit Corona bekommen ich
kenne Leute die drei Jahre wie ich weit
gehen zu Hause geblieben sind und jetzt
nicht mehr so richtig in die Spur kommen
ich habe z.B was ich nie im Leben hatte
ich habe seine leichte Allergie gegen
Reisen schon der Gedanke mich ins
Flugzeug zu setzen bereitet mir
sinngefühl das hat es nicht gegeben aber
wissen Sie wir alle Folgen einer wahren
Idee nämlich der Idee dass man das Klima
beeinflussen kann dass Menschen gemacht
hat nur eine kleine Korrektur wir sind
ein Prozent der Weltbevölkerung mit plus
minus 80 Millionen und unser Beitrag zum
co2-ausschuss bei 1,9 bis 2% und sie
haben vollkommen recht wenn Deutschland
morgen vom Erdboden verschwende was ich
sehr bedauern werde würde keiner mehr
und wenn sich auf die europäische Karte
gucken würde ich mir sogar in der ARD
eine dann sehen sie so überall die
Kernkraftwerke mit zunehmender Zahl und
in der Mitte ist ein großer weißer Fleck
das sind wir wir sind mal wieder das
Vorbild für die Welt und wir müssen
ständig irgendjemand von irgendwas
befreien und jetzt vor der Gefahr des
atomtodes das Argument ist ja auch oft
und sehr sie sind jetzt bei uns hier in
der Runde der jüngsten der jüngste wir
müssen die Schrauben einfach weiter
anziehen denn wir wollen die kommenden
die Jungen und kommenden Generationen
schützen muss man da einfach dann die
oben so eng anziehen also ich bin jetzt
wahrlich kein Fan vom Emissionshandel
ich finde das nicht das beste System es
ist auch unehrlich weil am Ende im
Moment gibt es noch gratis Zertifikate
die werden verschenkt am Ende wenn es zu
teuer würde würde sowieso würden mehr
Zertifikate reingegeben damit der Preis
nicht über die über die Maßen steigt von
daher ist diese FDP Vorstellung die
machen sich immer einfach machen
emissionszahlen dann machen wir können
uns das ganze Mikromanagement die ganzen
staatlichen Investitionen was die
kümmern uns alle sparen das ist alles
schön Rechnerei Einsatz zu den 2% sagen
Deutschland lässt natürlich heutzutage
mehr im Ausland produzieren ne also die
Emissionen die in China entstehen die
sollten wir ehrlicherweise auch uns zu
rechnen weil das Zeug was da produziert
keine
verantwortlich nein nein aber sie
konsumieren lassen
Südafrika wollen sie mir das auch noch
zurechnen
ehrlich wäre das ja aber völlig daneben
ehrlich wäre das machen sie mal ehrlich
Politik den kommen damit nicht weiter
machen sie ehrlich Politik Frau Ada sie
sitzen genau dort in der Politik und man
muss sagen man hat jetzt von der FDP
keinen riesigen Aufschrei gehört jetzt
in diesem Wochenende die AKWs sind jetzt
runter das ist nicht so ganz das was Sie
sich vorstellen aber die große
Barrikaden der große Protest hat der
stattgefunden gegen die nur an uns
vorbei
der der große Prozess hat er intern
stattgefunden die AKWs hätten eigentlich
ja schon Ende letzten Jahres vom Netz
gehen sollen wir haben noch meine
Verlängerung jetzt bis April er wirken
können so dass wir wenigstens erstmal
durch den Winter kommen dass die
Atomkraftwerke jetzt vom Netz gegangen
sind bedeutet zwei zunächst erst einmal
dass wir aus der
Atom verstummung ausgestiegen sind aber
wir sollten und wir dürfen nicht aus der
Forschung aussteigen also da müssen wir
mindestens dran bleiben
am Ende ist es immer eine Sache von
Kompromissen in Koalition ihre Wähler
wollen das nicht zum großen Teil ja sie
selber ja auch nicht also ihr
Fraktionsvorsitzender doch noch ganz
groß getönt wie hat die FDP sein wird
und die Leute sind und da kann ich nur
jedem sagen gucken Sie immer die
Abstimmungen an die namentlichen
Abstimmung und gucken sie genau wer wie
abgestimmt hat da fallen sie ja in
Ohnmacht die Leute die gestern noch
gesagt haben wir brauchen die Kernkraft
geben treu ihre Stimme ab
da sollte man genau gucken wofür man
oder was man abstimmt und das was sie
jetzt vermutlich das was sie jetzt
vermutlich ansprechen das ist ein
Entschließungsantrag der CDU gewesen das
war noch nicht mein Gesetzentwurf das
waren reiner Entschließungsantrag ja das
ist ein scheinantrag und letztendlich
sind wir also auch als FDP sind wir uns
einig und klar dass wir die Kernenergie
nicht komplett sein lassen dürfen ganz
im Gegenteil wir müssen weiter forschen
und die Meiler die Meiler jetzt auf
jeden Fall erstmal betriebsbereit oder
startklarheiten also die dürfen jetzt
nicht schwimmen doch aus Frankreich den
atomstorben wie erklären sie denn das
Volk muss doch dumm sein wenn es das
nicht begreift ich glaube nicht dass es
das Volk nicht begreift ich und die auch
die FDP hat das begriffen nur im
Augenblick ist die Situation so in einer
Demokratie braucht man mehr halten und
in der Koalition in der wir uns befinden
haben wir dafür jetzt die Mehrheit
bekommen allerdings
und rechtfertigen können Sie mir
überhaupt erklären wie es kommt das in
der Bundesrepublik wenn ich mich nicht
irre immer noch Atom Brennstäbe
produziert werden die dann eine andere
Länder geliefert werden das heißt wir
haben keine Atommeiler mehr und die
Begründung einer der Begründungen war
ich war zur umständlich die jetzt zum
Bestellen und auch noch bei den Russen
und jetzt höre ich es gibt Betriebe die
Kernbrennstäbe hier herstellen und ja
finden Sie einen gewissen Widerspruch
oder um zu sagen Widerspruch haben wir
ja nicht aufgelegt also
in der Regierung oder habe ich mich
vertan ist das schon wieder vorbei nein
aber wir bauen doch jetzt Windräder
überall und gestern wird plötzlich
festgestellt dass die Blätter von den
Windrädern nicht recyclebar sind das
heißt wir haben jetzt Millionen von
diesen Blättern für diese Windräder die
nicht recycelt werden
das ist doch der große schick der Ampel
sie will doch alles recyceln jetzt ist
das Haupt Energie der Haupt
Energieträger weil er in Deutschland so
viel Wind ist nicht ja wir machen ja vor
allem im Süden so wird jetzt plötzlich
kommt jetzt raus dass diese diese
Blätter von der Autoren das ist alles so
wahnsinnig wie es schlimmer gar nicht
geht aber sie wollen bestimmt einen
günstigen Strompreis haben natürlich
sicherlich einen Winter es gibt alles
klar ich möchte
deswegen
Windkraft und Solarkraft sein denn das
ist übrigens das viel größere Potenzial
die Mehrwert davon haben und hätten wir
davon jetzt in der Krise schon mehr
gehabt wäre der Strompreis gar nicht so
hoch gewesen wenn die Belastung
beispielsweise für die Energie intensive
Industrie die hat nämlich am meisten
gelitten am meisten Produktionsstopps er
wirken müssen wäre gar nicht so groß
gewesen
die schöne Landschaft des Taunus oder
die sind doch Wahnsinn das ganze Land
mit diesen blöden absolut ihre Idee dass
man
automobilbetriebe und Kohlegruben und
Stahlwerke mit ja und ja
BASF braucht am Tag so viel wie Dänemark
ich würde noch ich würde noch ganz kurz
was zu dem billigen Strompreis sagen ich
glaube es ist eine mehr wenn man denkt
je mehr Windräder oder Solaranlagen wir
bauen die billiger wird der Strom wir
haben immer noch das married order
System und da ist halt der teuerste
Energieerzeuger maßgebend für den Preis
und das sind im Augenblick nicht die
Windräder und nicht die Solaranlagen
sondern eher Kohle und Gas und wir haben
die Atomkraftwerke bestehende
Atomkraftwerke jetzt vom Netz genommen
wir werden in also wir müssen eine
Versorgungssicherheit herstellen das
heißt wenn wir künftig äh die Lücke
schließen müssen wir möglicherweise
viele Gaskraftwerke neu bauen und das
wird wahrscheinlich auch oder sehr
wahrscheinlich auch den Preis den
Strompreis nach oben treiben das ist
auch auch mal einer meiner Kritiken weil
man jetzt immer wieder denkt die
erneuerbaren Energien die sind zu
preiswert und die machen die Strom
billiger das ist falsch weil durch
dieses Problem der Strom teuer bleibt
weil wir teure
Werke da haben uns jetzt noch
Kohlekraftwerke wieder vermehrt ans Netz
erneuerbare wir haben desto weniger Gas
muss aber überhaupt verstromt werden im
Schnitt sind das 10% unseres Stroms die
aus Gas kommen hätten wir mehr Wind und
so Strom aus Wind und Sonne gehabt
hätten wir die Gaskraftwerke gar nicht
für die
Stromkraftwerke und wenn die dann auch
abgeschaltet werden müssen wir die Lücke
schließen
Energien aus der erneuerbaren Energie
das wird seit Jürgen Trittin verbreitet
gerade am Anfang der ganzen Geschichte
gesagt die Umstellung auf die neuerbaren
Erneuerbaren wird jeden Haushalt so viel
kosten wie eine Kugel Eis das waren
damals 50 Cent das ist ein Märchen
wissen Sie dass es wo du was sie hier
betreiben Frau Göring-Eckardt der hat
vor kurzem erklärt wenn die
Kernkraftwerke abgeschaltet werden wenn
der Strom billiger ich meine wir
schalten seit Jahren Kernkraftwerke ab
und der Strom ist nur teurer geworden
ihre Rechnung geht nicht auf aber eines
Wunsch denke ja aber eines Tages können
wir wir blicken jetzt in die Geschichte
wo wir Erfahrung haben die Römer hatten
die Galeeren wo die Menschen den Motor
gespielt haben ähm
dann können wir doch jetzt alle pusten
weil wir ja keinen Wind haben wir wollen
das waren die Seite überzeugen ja das
sind doch das ist ja das sind doch alles
Windbeutel die unsicher also es wird
schon viel gepustet ja
Windbeutel das ist so ein Thema jetzt
sind wir schon mittendrin Herren in
ihrem Zimmer ich möchte einmal Frau
aller fragen was sie haben auch gesagt
ja das ist nicht ganz unsere Position
wir müssen aber Kompromisse eingehen wie
schwer ist das für sie wie schwer merken
Sie auch dass Politiker zunehmend mit
der Glaubwürdigkeit zu kämpfen haben
wenn man Kompromisse eingehen muss
hinter denen man eigentlich soll ich das
raus nicht steht
es fällt teilweise schon schwer
gerade jetzt bei der Atomenergie wenn
man da hört dass unsere grünen
Koalitionspartner ist feiern dass wir
aus der Atomenergie ausgestiegen sind
weil sie ja schon seit den 80er Jahren
dafür kämpfen wir mittlerweile aber in
einer völlig anderen Zeit leben und das
nicht mal mit den 80er Jahren
vergleichbar ist wir hätten eine
Energiewende haben können mit billigen
Gas möglicherweise aus Russland das ist
weggefallen also wir haben komplett neue
Voraussetzung und da ist man schon in
dem Glauben und in der Hoffnung dass
auch unsere Koalitionspartner
insbesondere die grünen
Koalitionspartner da einlenken und davon
Vernunft üben ist leider nicht so sie
bestehen drauf sie bestehen auf ihren ja
jahrelang Kampf und dort möglicherweise
so hörte sich das leider auch an Sieg
davon getragen zu haben und hier geht's
aber nicht um Sieg oder Niederlage hier
geht's ganz schlecht um Deutschland und
um die Existenz Deutschlands und da
Deutschland braucht Preis Wert und
billige Energie und das wird leider ja
vergessen und da hätte ich mir gewünscht
das auch unsere Koalitionspartner die
ist in anderen Situationen ja können die
sich der Situation anpassen können auch
in der Situation der eine Energiefrage
anpassen sie abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung das
kann ich Wahnsinn jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
wild kämpft für Sie